my question is this though because I'm
hearing all of the right things and yet
we have a panel of five single women so
where's the disconnect what's not
working uh for me right now you know I'm
not I'm not open to being remarried I'm
not open to being partnered um I spent a
lot of years raising my children they're
all adults and now I'm creating two
businesses so that is my focus that's
something I'm very passionate about and
helping others um in Christianity women
of my age were called upon to help
younger women we're called upon to help
younger single women and younger married
women so that is the role that I have
taken on right now and quite frankly I'm
going to be honest with you um for
feminine women like myself there really
are only two options in the world when
it comes to you know happiness and
health and relationships number one be
gloriously single have a life you love
create a life you love and live it or
number two be with a healthy masculine
High character man I don't do anything
in between I've had a lot of stuff in
between those two things knock on my
door and I I'm not interested so if that
man is not a high moral High character
man if he is not you know willing to you
know become my husband and we hold each
other in high regard if he's not willing
to be faithful I have a life I love and
I've created you know a life that I love
I've been married I have a family I have
three grown children and I have a great
life you know I have work that I'm
passionate about I have the most amazing
friends um I have a lot of hobbies and a
lot of interests so right now that's the
space that I live in but I'm I'm not
open or available right
now just a few comments from people just
uh feeding back back
there I'm into the whole because M you
were asking like why are we single why
are we in this position um for me
specifically I have had like not even
just like take away cheating out of the
relationships that I've been in but like
emotional verbal abuse physical abuse
and that's like some of the things that
keep me from dating because it's kind of
hard to like put yourself out there um
and what is what is verbal abuse because
I sorry I just want to deal with the
whole abuse thing because I hear that
pop up a lot like he abusive emotional
abuse Financial abuse verbal like what
are we talking about here uh verbal
abuse as in like I had an ex that I
could literally say nothing and he would
literally look at me and tell me that
I'm the biggest piece of [__] that has
ever walked the Earth and I'm this and
I'm that and I'm just like you you
called me to tell me this like for what
like I was asleep nothing happened and
you just randomly wanted to call me and
tell me that and I think it's more of
like a power trip for him to know why
did you why did you choose him why did
you get into a relationship that didn't
happen until like a year into the
relationship a year into it you saw that
yes and then you cut cut ties in oh I
just left okay yeah yeah but it was one
of those that was like leading more
towards physical because he would
randomly like punch doors and throw
stuff that was like in my direction and
not just to Sho like heavy things and I
was like hm and that's like something
that I I don't want to say that all men
are gonna do it because they're not
there's good men out there and then
there's bad men out there just like
there's good women and bad women but I'm
scared to date because I I keep thinking
that like it's going to happen again
it's going to be like a very trigger in
huge you know like thing to heal from
what about you Veronica why are you
single uh I spent most of my 20s in a
longterm committed relationship so I've
been single for about a year now the guy
you cheated on sorry was that the guy
that you cheated on no guy okay uh and
so I'd say like I've met some pretty
high value men in the past I think the
first six Mones coming out of the
relationship I wasn't dating at all and
I've met a few um and I'm kind of in a
place where I'm thinking hopefully
within the next few years I'll find that
connection um but it's been interesting
navigating dating now versus in my early
20s so how's it different now uh I mean
obviously the dating app
is a whole new thing um I think like I
wasn't obviously dating for the same
reasons uh I was like now I'm I'm
definitely looking at so many other
factors like do we want the same
lifestyle do we want you know like
there's just so much more that I never
would have even considered at that time
and why didn't you end up marrying the
guy you were with in your
20s um actually a lot of those reasons
we kind of grew apart instead of
together we had very different uh I
think lifestyle was a huge one um I kind
of was very career- driven and him not
so much um I think I started to realize
that the type of man that I wanted
wasn't within that relationship so so he
got he got a little bit lazy and slow in
the relationship comfortable maybe
even yeah it was comfortable you were
growing sorry and you were
growing I mean the relationship probably
wasn't my priority throughout that yeah
like it sounds like you were growing
outside of the relationship rather than
in it yeah correct yeah okay all right
Jackie why are why are you here today
why are you single why am I single or
why am I here today bit of both I guess
um well I've been single for about a
year and um I do go on dates but I also
have my business and um I feel like in
my last relationship I gave a lot of
myself in my life and he almost became
like a huge part of my life so when that
ended about a year ago you know I needed
to like find myself again and create my
own life and in the midst of it continue
building my business so dating takes
time like it's extremely time consuming
for me so I can only date so much and
and um continue to work on myself and
pour to myself so I just haven't met the
right person you know probably because I
don't date a ton are you like is anybody
on the panel looking to get married yeah
everybody with the exception of Anita
it's kind of like if it shows up then it
shows up you're not really look I'm not
looking to get married to for now yeah
well you just got divorced you know
within the first year so that's
understandable yeah okay so most of you
are actually looking to get married I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out